[Music]
ah amsterdam the canals the weed the
bikes there are a lot of bikes here i
think well i found the drugstore
[Music]
there are 165 canals in amsterdam
totaling over 60 miles in length and
resting on the ground in these canals
are bikes
lots of bikes
these two guys
they're bike fishermen they pull bikes
out of canals in amsterdam
[Music]
i'm just gonna ask the obvious why why
are there so many bikes in the water
[Music]
the machine they use is basically an
oversized claw machine it goes into the
water and pulls out bikes
most bikes are found near the edges of
the canals
[Music]
[Music]
amsterdam
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
every year the world's most elite
mountain bikers gather in france for a
race unlike any other
it's
the longest
tony race in the world
that's right mcavalanch is the longest
downhill race in the world 18 miles long
10 000 feet high in the french alps and
a crazy starting line of 3 000 cyclists
on a mountain peak this is remy absalon
he won the mc avalanche
i started mountain bike when i was young
enduro and mountain bike is
really cool because we can explore all
around the world
mecca avalanche alperus takes place
since the french alps in halperduez so
not so far of italy and switzerland
it's a
really high in harps so you have a
very good
view 360 degrees
around you
it's really crazy i don't know why
i do that
you ride all kinds of terrain first the
glacier and after the rocky section the
forest
it's very physical with
some happiness so when you cross the
line and you are first
you're you're really happy and
you want to to try again
[Music]
the penny farthing was the first machine
to be called a bicycle
[Music]
they're old they're funny and for some
it's still a big deal uh sometimes i go
into a local bike shop just for a bit of
a joke and ask me if i've got a tire to
fit my bike and then bring him outside
have a look at it
[Music]
people find that the funny farving
almost hypnotic i don't know why i can't
explain it but people just love seeing
it and it's just a real pleasure to
share it with people richard being an
already avid bike racer discovered penny
farthing racing on an internet forum one
night
so i entered immediately uh very excited
and then realized that a i don't have a
penny farthing and b i don't know how to
ride a penny farthing but he overcame
those hurdles
i'm the current uk champion uh so i've
got title defend
but penny farthing racing isn't as easy
as it looks and it sure doesn't look
easy it's a very dangerous machine to
ride you're sat up on top on the point
of balance virtually so if anything goes
wrong you tend to be going headfirst
over the front of the bike the bikes can
be up to five feet tall and that height
has its benefits racing one of these
bikes uh pretty high up you get a
fantastic view of the crowd it's the
best way to see the event here i always
tell people height is not the only
benefit the penny farthing has big
difference between riding a funny
farthing and a normal bike
is you can't slow down very quickly
you've got to watch the road ahead but i
find the biggest difference is the
smiles on people's faces when you ride
one of these things people just love to
see it they smile they wave they pull up
take photographs
i've so many conversations with people i
would never ever meet without this bike
and that's the joy that people just love
seeing it talking about it
[Music]
[Music]
in a city that loves its bikes there is
one man looking out for the rest one man
brave enough to bring bike thieves to
justice a man the city calls
bike batman
in reality i'm just an engineer
back in the early 2000s i started really
noticing you know there's a lot of bike
theft i remember i had a set of wheels
stolen i was livid i was super poor and
there was
nothing to do you know i couldn't
recover them it was so frustrating for
me knowing that the police are so busy
with so many other crimes in seattle
that there was nobody following up on
these minor incidents
enough was enough he realized he needed
to take the law into his own hands and
he had the perfect plan
i would best describe bike index as a
database that allows you to register
your bicycle it's a great way to search
for stolen bikes
the way it works for me is as i'm
cruising craigslist i'll notice a fishy
ad and i will immediately open up bike
index and do a quick search
for any bikes that have been stolen in
that geographic area
the first time that i recovered a bike i
had no idea what it was doing i drove
after work to go meet this guy and it
wasn't one person i was meeting it was
three
and
i told him you know guys the cops are on
the way i just called him this bike is
stolen and you're not gonna be leaving
with it eventually through the bike in
my truck burned out returned the bike it
felt great
what began as a simple plan to help a
fellow cyclist took on a life of its own
seattle's own bike vigilante was born
we were able to recover
high 30s or low 40s of bikes
i'm not entirely sure when the bike
vigilante had become a thing it was
probably when the bike batman moniker
was given to me and this is just
something you know i like doing i don't
need or want you know any recognition
just doing good is essentially you know
how i try to live my life and thanks to
bike batman the cyclists of emerald city
can rest easy
once more
[Music]
when i'm out there riding my bike and i
have this pump on it's almost like it's
not even there i just feel the freedom
of being out there and feeling the speed
and adrenaline
it's just hanging out there riding her
bike
some might say i'm like dorothy explorer
because i'm always wearing this backpack
but this backpack keeps me alive
[Music]
my name is hannah jordan i'm from tulsa
oklahoma i'm 15 years old and i'm a
competitive cyclist
my long-term goals are to become pro and
be in the olympics in 2020 for tokyo and
bring back the tour de france for women
i have an unknown rare metabolic disease
from when i was very little i was in and
out of the hospital and very sick all
the time and when i was nine they gave
me only a couple months to live
it's like i sort of skipped childhood
my mom took me all over the country to
some specialists and they found a
solution and they gave me a thing called
a g-tube that pumps sugar into my
stomach
it basically keeps my blood sugar at a
normal rate
i've always wanted to do competitive
stuff but for most of my life i couldn't
play sports because of my condition
when i got on the bike it was almost
like my problems weren't there
it's just been like a whole new world
open up to me
this one right here is really special
this was her first one and it's a silver
medal but she'd actually only been
riding a bike two months and then
shortly after that she did this one she
did 101 miles in five hours and 18
minutes which is very very fast
and that's kind of when we realized that
she probably was going to be pretty good
at this
this weekend i will be competing in
tulsa tough a three-day race
each day a thousand racers compete from
six different countries around the world
these women are usually 20 and above
my mom and my dad they're my biggest
supporters they take me to all the races
and help me make it in cycling
my mom she helps me get everything ready
and my dad at the 200 meter mark he
starts yelling
it's like a mental marker of like when i
start needing to sprint
what makes me different from other
cycles is the ability to tap in that
will power and determination
i like to tell people it's sort of coded
in my dna to be a fighter
anyone that's been in the hospital for a
long time or has gone through some
struggles or pain or suffering they just
know how to dig deep and tap in and to
be resilient
and even if you lose some days and you
win some others you have to keep getting
back up each and every single time to go
out there and ride your bike
[Music]
you